this is awesome you know i saw an
interview with you and you talked about
getting the role of um
detective gordon um
and it was what made me think of this
interview was when i got lex luther
people ask me the questions like did you
watch gene hackman did you do the
research
what did you do and i thought ah this is
kind of like
you know i know that you were playing
him younger though like before right
it's the earlier years
so were you putting a lot of stress on
yourself because you knew the fan base
was so huge and
well sure for sure but that's like such
a such a like
vague pressure to put on yourself like
don't [ __ ] this up how how what's the
specific thing you know what i mean and
so you
you the way i work is you definitely
stress out about it you definitely like
just
freak out and then you go okay well
so that's like that's probably
undergirding everything for like
multiple seasons and certainly the first
season but
but then you go all right well how do i
channel this into something
mildly productive and then you go it's
actually a great scenario and i will say
my conversations with bruno heller who
created gotham
you know who sort of the way the way
this happened is
the year prior to gotham bruno and i did
a pilot for cbs
which never got picked up um it was me
and mandy moore
actually oh she's so sweet she's awesome
she's a doll
uh and we hit it off bruno and i
the pilot didn't go but i was under a
deal at warner brothers after that and
unbeknownst to me
vernon was writing gotham and and they
had sold it
and he called me you know the following
like january or february the following
year and was like hey
i wrote this part you know with you in
mind like take a look at it
and i was like that's cool like that's
no one's ever written a part
for me ever or since
[Laughter]
perhaps more telling um but like you
know so i read it and i was like well
yeah
this is you know it was hard to argue
against
how cool the idea is um so much so that
that uh and i don't want to get ahead of
ourselves you might even do the same
idea again
if you wanted to to do good cop show set
in gotham city
you could do it again even after you've
done gotham um do you know about this
no okay so what was cool about it it was
was
the bruno talked to me about how
in some senses you you sort of are free
of
doing some you know
commissioner gordon copy whether you're
copying old men or or whomever
because you're just seeing them in a
completely different chapter of their
lives i mean you're seeing rookie police
detective jim gordon so
he's in his late 20s maybe you know uh
uh even though i was in my mid-thirties
people saying
where's his english accent wasn't he
like gary oldman
look i'm the pres now it's funny well
what's funny is that bruno
and danny cannon who directed the pilot
was our other main ep besides
um john stephen both both english like
so they both talk actually like
gary and i think danny even danny even
knows gary and like plays soccer
used to play soccer with him and um
yeah no i mean it just felt like look
we're doing something completely
different and and and quite frankly i
mean
as good as gary oldman is and he is
pretty phenomenally talented and
successful
you know what he was doing in the movies
is so different
than the role that gordon needs to play
in the series because gordon in the
series is the focus of the show and
needs to play that
you know i in my opinion always felt
like and this is definitely i think what
i think bruno would agree is like he
needed to be a little bit of that every
man
needed to have a little bit of that you
know kind of chip on his shoulder
you know young guy in a big bad world
not beaten down yet to have somewhere to
go you have an arc
you have somewhere to go yeah yeah and
ironically you know
what i loved about it the thing that i
loved about it from a
character journey standpoint is most of
the time in most series you see a
character
succeed and succeed and succeed and like
their arc just think that they overcome
obstacles presenting themselves to keep
overcoming them without coming on their
way to
to you know fulfillment right like you
could argue maybe even like
like um uh you know welling's character
and smallville right like he's
slowly gonna become superman but here
not only is our guy not the kind of
becoming a superhero he's literally just
a flesh and blood man
he as he ascends up the ark of the
police
you know hierarchy the city falls apart
the city like descends into anarchy
and has to like more and more in order
to necessitate batman in order to
necessitate
like what what we're ending with which
is that there is a batman
so it's like he's going up as everything
else is falling apart which i think is
such a
cool you know kind of inversion of the
usual
circumstances um so i really dug that
and bruno is
you know pretty much a genius and and so
he was he was always smarter than me
about about
sort of contextualizing it and making me
feel like okay cool well i mean
the worst that'll happen is you know it
doesn't the show doesn't quite work or
maybe
i'm not as good as something i'm never
as good as i hope i would be
uh um but but it's not
it's not based on like my impression of
a vague jim gordon
you know what i mean like there's no
yeah i mean i feel the same way if i
would have been like i'm gonna do gene
hackman i'm like
hey clark how's it going and just you
know and by the way gene hackman's my
favorite but
honestly i said just play it real
just be genuine be real have emotions
and once i shaved my [ __ ] head what
you didn't have to do
it just that i was like all right i'm
here i'm ready put on a suit
oh look i wear short i'm wearing shorts
sandals and a t-shirt this is how i
dress nor
you put on a suit and two or 300 shoes
and a tie
and give me a mansion and shave my head
i am going to be
different yeah and i needed all that so
but for you
it was like hey i'm ben mckenzie they're
going to do my hair a little bit it's
going to be in a different time
but did you did you feel like day one
you felt like
i feel like this guy i i feel like it i
felt like they had all of those things
that you talked about all those
resources were so teed up i mean i
remember
we shot a pilot we were not picked up to
series you know
officially yet but i walked into this
two-story
gcpd set that they built
it was gotta be i forget on my somebody
told me how much it cost but it's
definitely a million dollar set if not
more
and you know to build a million dollar
two to two story set
i'd never been on a two-story set and
never been in a set where you could have
multiple open levels
um and 200 background
inside of a set before and
i remember showing up and thankfully
they'd walked me through
you know i got to see see it before i
had to
film there and going okay all right got
it i know
it's gonna have all the toys behind you
like you're gonna have all the
the settings gonna be there you're gonna
have the clothes you're gonna have the
the the manpower so to speak to like
support the fact that you were supposed
to be a leader of men
like jim gordon now you need to be a
leader
now you need to the rest is up to you
that's see that's anxiety that's like
you're sitting there you're looking to
set going yep yep i'm
pretending i'm confident and inside
you're about to [ __ ] your pants and
you're going
yeah yeah i got to step it up man i
gotta [ __ ] step it up
i remember the first shot of the first
day we were in the set
there were at least a hundred probably
200 background
it was this whole scene or something
some guy some bad guy been
been pulled in and arrested
and he breaks free of of the officers
that are
trying to slam him in the in the jail
cell in the set
and and i and i appear magically on this
upper deck and like come down and and
disarm them
save the day and that's my introduction
right super heroic introduction so it's
great
and we're doing the rehearsals and data
down we finally start rolling and
and i'm literally i basically come down
you know descend from the rafters you
know
i wasn't on uh wires but i might as well
have been
um you know juicy pd you know i you know
unhand him or whatever and and i
literally remember going
geez my voice cracked i almost
tripped on the stairs like i literally
went
because my nerves were i was shy my
adrenaline was
out of control